this is a preliminary set of details
about their webinar I'm Peter Cooper
errata Morris is going to be presenting
this and she'll be on in just a minute
any questions we get with their answers
will be available after the webinar
they'll be linked to our webinars page
they will also be in the materials
directory on the FTP site that shortcut
link there go usa.gov slash X in capital
Z to lowercase B will get you there so
with that I'm going to turn this over to
Rana hi guys thank you for joining us
today
today's talk will be about keeping
current and getting help with ncbi
resources in this short webinar you'll
learn several ways that can help you
keep up to date with changes and updates
that are happening at ncbi on our web
site and with our data and also where to
look and ways to find help using ncbi
resources as a US government agency and
part of the national every of medicine
we are always keep in mind that we're
here to serve you we have a specific
mission to perform computational and
data analysis research gathered data
from all over the globe create systems
to enable you to access and use our data
and help you figure out how to use it as
part of this mission we're not only
putting on this webinar today but have
created various mechanisms to
communicate with you about all the cool
things going on here at NCBI and help
you learn how to use them and also
provide help in helping you use them
just to recap about what you up may
already know we've got lots and lots of
databases with lots of different kinds
of data currently there are over 40
different databases available on the
NCBI website we also create lots of
tools to help you access and analyze the
data in those databases we're updating
existing and creating new resources all
the time within those databases are a
huge amount of data which is constantly
being added to some of these databases
are updated every day and some are
updated regularly such as GenBank with
specific periodic releases for those of
you who have visited our website over
the years you may have noticed that some
of our pages still look similar to how
they did when they were first released
we are in the process of updating our
pages to provide an easier to read and
use layout of our data this is a new
initiative at NCBI and you'll see some
major changes coming up up in the next
couple of years for example for the DB
snip pages which have been around for
over a decade we're now testing out a
new design which we hope will help snip
users find what they are looking for
more easily and quickly we have a
feedback button that's the green button
on the side over here and would really
like to hear what you think about these
pages what you like and what works well
for you as well as what you think we
might change to make it even better in
addition to creating better web pages
for you we're also looking at what is
under the hood to improve what you see
back after you do a search an example
here is the new pubmed labs project
which is testing a new search algorithm
to improve how literature results are
found in the process we're also testing
out new modern displays and even adding
cool new functionality with it PubMed
Labs is a sandbox to test all this out
and the things that we find here are
going to be really good and helpful and
the ones that people like and can use
will eventually add to improve to the
regular PubMed interfaces so we're
trying cool new stuff all the time this
is a lot of stuff and a lot of stuff
going on at NCBI new data every day
updated functionality updated web page
layouts new resources and cool new
things coming online all the time how
can you keep up with it all we've got a
lot of channels to help you with this
there are many ways to find out what's
new at NCBI and many different tutorial
and help documents designed to help you
learn how to use our resources we even
have put online very recently a new NCBI
Support Center designed to help you find
answers to your questions and to assist
in sending messages to our help desk to
get your specific questions answered
don't worry about all these icons for
now we'll go through them all I also
have a cheat sheet at the end of this
presentation which summarizes pretty
succinctly everything that you need to
know and will tell you how to get a copy
of this cheat sheet for yourself so
amongst the vastness of the NCBI website
where is a good place to start to learn
about what's new at NCBI
here's the NCBI homepage I'll show you
how to access a lot of the things from a
single page I'm gonna recommend that you
start at the NCBI learn site which will
connect you to everything we'll talk
about today pretty much on a single page
click on the learn to get to this learn
page you may have seen this page before
but if you haven't it's pretty
worthwhile this is where we announce all
of our NCBI minute webinars like the one
that you're looking at today click on
the webinars and courses box and it'll
take you to a list of teaching events
about what we're doing here's the
webinar that you're in today and here's
where you did or you could have
registered to participate while most of
you probably heard about this webinar on
Twitter or Facebook there's a reason to
come to this webinars and courses page
here is where we put links to all the
materials for the webinar as soon as
it's been done we'll put up the
PowerPoint slides that you're actually
seeing a Q&A document answering
questions you may have that we haven't
had time to cover live and for this
particular webinar I've got a cheat
sheet in there that I mentioned and I'm
gonna tell you about later on finally
we'll also put a link to the video made
of this webinar that we'll put up on
YouTube in a few days while many of you
may just want to watch the YouTube video
on YouTube I know several of you might
like the powerpoints from our webinar
presentations to use either to update
yourself or to use with your colleagues
back to the main learn page on the right
hand side you may notice something that
looks a lot like what was on the main
NCBI home page also an ncbi news and
blog section with titles and links this
is indeed the same and we also have
another place where you can get to our
insulin CBI insights blog on the bottom
here's where we make major and minor
announcements provide some answers and
how-tos for frequently asked questions
and basically let people know what's
going on here at NCBI and on our website
for example last week we did another one
of these NCBI minute webinars to let
people who write scripts and code know
about a new tool an API key that we're
making available to help them better
access our servers this is a wordpress
style
so if you have a wordpress account you
can set up to get email alerts or an RSS
feed information about how the new posts
that come out we've also created several
other social media accounts and link
them here to provide this information if
you don't have a WordPress account or
prefer to use Twitter or Facebook or
LinkedIn instead you don't have to go
through the NCBI insights blog to get to
our social media accounts back on our
learn page again we've got two different
spots where you can get to our feeds
channels or sites for your favorite
social media platforms
you're welcome to sign up to follow us
on any of these social media sites
Twitter Facebook and LinkedIn where we
even have showcase pages where we
segregate notifications into those
pertinent areas of genomes genes
proteins chemicals literature and health
related subjects keep in mind that
everything that goes out on the NCBI
insights blog is also announced on each
of these other social media platforms so
you don't need to worry that you'll miss
anything you can just pick one that
you're most comfortable with and it'll
be able to let you know what's going on
we also have an ncbi announce email
listserv for those people who would
prefer to be notified in their email
INBOX we also have an ncbi announce RSS
feed for people using that mode just to
let you know though while we often
announce our participating participation
in various scientific and clinical
conferences on all of our social media
sites sometimes we'll tweet more about
it to let those people who are attending
know and also include hashtags for the
event but for the most part you won't
miss any of our news or announcements
regardless of whichever social media
site you prefer to use you certainly
don't need to follow them all now you
found out how to be notified of
goings-on at NCBI news and and other
announcements but how can you figure out
how to use the cool new things you've
learned about back on the NCBI learn
page first there are those webinars like
the one coming up there is one coming up
about quick blastp hint hint
you might want to sign up for it and the
blog sometimes we have posts showing you
how to find gene symbols and all their
aliases or how
use the genome data viewer for example
but we also have written and video
tutorials as well as help documents to
help you figure out how to do something
we also try to fully use our YouTube
channel not just to show these short
webinars but we also have short one to
three minute videos showing you how to
do something very specific on our site
as well we have a lot of different
videos and even a lot of different
playlists here many of these are
actually linked directly from our pages
to provide help others are often viewed
after a simple web search to find a
helpful video for very specific help
using a particular resource let's say a
database or a tool we recommend that you
look at the actual home page for that
resource the developers for those
resources will often put helpful links
on the left hand side of the page to
assist you in learning how to use their
baby most of the time on our site
there's also a help link in the upper
right-hand corner of the page which will
help take you to the main help
documentation for that page or that
particular resource here's the gene
database homepage which has those help
links on the left and some quick search
terms at the bottom and it also has that
main help link in the upper right hand
corner just like PubMed did our blast
homepage also has a help link in the
upper right both on a home page and it's
still there when you go to any
particular blast page as well more
complex tools have their own
documentation sometimes is simple help
and sometimes more here's a picture of
the variation viewer which in the again
upper right hand corner has help and
also an FAQ link to answer frequently
asked questions but it also has a direct
link to helpful videos on our YouTube
channel as well those links that were on
the left hand side of the home pages
they often go to help manuals and FAQ
chapters on our NCBI bookshelf there's a
lot of help there
that you can either get to from a
particular resource or you can go to the
books database and do a search we really
recommend the NCBI Handbook
which has chapters for each major
database and tool and describes pretty
technical aspects of the resources like
scope history where the data comes from
how to access it and related tools and
resources but for more specific and
practical help with how to use a
resource there are a lot of different
help manuals which were designed just to
do that to show you how to use the
resource practically finally if you need
specific help to answer a question we
have a brand new resource for you and it
can be accessed in virtually any footer
that we have in at NCBI even if they
look a bit different on the bottom right
hand corner you'll see the link to the
NCBI Support Center the NCBI Support
Centre is a place where you can find
discreet answers to important questions
some of the questions are can I get a
subscription to access all the journals
in PubMed through NCBI how do I cite
blast in my manuscript how can I find
all the protein sequences that belong to
a specific protein family how can I find
a genome from my organism of interest
and a whole lot of more questions as
well if you still can't quite figure out
the answer to your question there is a
link to write to the help desk on the
top of the page which will help create a
help ticket for a member of our help
desk to answer we will do our best to
answer the question and get right back
to you within two working days often
you'll actually get a response quicker
than that please note that we do not
answer user help requests on our social
media platforms such as Twitter or
Facebook as the space limitations and
postings prevents us from really being
able to help as much as we need to also
we don't have the personnel to be able
to monitor all the channels so we really
go through directly through the help
desk link here and yes those of you who
are familiar with it can still use the
old NCBI help desk email address which
is funneled through our new system and
that email address is still info at NCBI
LMT nih gov now that's a lot of stuff
and a lot of resources and sites to
remember here's my cheat sheet for you
which really summarizes pretty much what
I've talked about hopefully in a
helpful in a succinct way I've created a
JPEG version of this slide and have
actually put it in the webinars
materials directory which you can find
on that learn webinars page
I hope this image which you are welcome
to print out use and distribute may make
it easier for you to figure out how to
keep up with what's going on at NCBI and
how to find help we'll also send you a
direct link for this particular graphic
in a follow-up email after this webinar
thank you for that your attention
that'll be happy to take any questions
you might have
ok thanks your honor there aren't any
questions in the questions pod at the
moment if you have any please enter them
we'll leave the webinar open for a
couple of minutes to see if we collect
any questions ok I think that's it for
today then thanks everyone for coming
and we'll see you next time
you